wir bleiben bei dem thema kroner wir
bleiben bei dem thema impfpflicht bei
herr müller ist war es war richtig
wohltuend das mal zu hören dass ja auch
das impfen die freiheit von jedem
einzelnen ich zeige ihnen jetzt etwas
ich glaube das wird sie in amerika
wahrscheinlich ebenso schockieren die
mich in mein thema ist heute abend nicht
die die nicht die ungeimpften rauben uns
die freiheit sondern die politiker ich
bin ja ein sehr sehr viel unsinn gewöhnt
und auch an plumpe erklärungen an
ausreden warum alles so bleiben und
plumpe stimmungsmache von politikern
lauterbach hat beispielsweise bei
menschen die sich nicht gegen kurve 19
haben impfen lassen gesagt das ganze
land wird in der geiselhaft dieser
menschen sein das muss man sich mal
vorstellen als gesundheitsminister so
etwas spielerisches zu sagen aber heute
heute wurde ich dann so richtig
überrascht beziehungsweise hat mich
völlig schockiert die jüngste
bundestagsabgeordnete emilia fester hat
heute wirklich in der impfpflicht
debatte allen davor da gewesen die krone
aufgesetzt und hören sie doch jetzt mal
gemeinsam mit ralf möller ich denke die
beiden studio kennen schon rein wie
emilia fest dass ich heute aufgeführt
hat
das macht ihn jetzt vielleicht
lächerlich vorkommen aber wissen sie was
wirklich lächerlich ist wenn sie uns
ihre freund in der freiheit sich einfach
hätten impfen lassen als die meisten von
uns so vernünftig waren in diesen
einfachen schritt gegangen sind dann
dann wäre ich jetzt nein
denn wir alle wieder frei oder zumindest
um das zu machen was wir lieben und
beruf jetzt seit zwei jahren warten was
manche von uns depressiv macht ja rolle
ja hass depressiv ich muss emilia fässer
in der stelle enttäuschen weil emilia
festern auch wir alle werden unsere
freiheit nicht zurück erlangen indem wir
menschen zur impfung zwingen sondern wir
bekommen die freiheit zurück wenn die
politik endlich umdenken und das schöne
ist ich hab ja heute in der runde ein
unions abgeordneten sitzen und da ist
natürlich meine frage an sie herr plus
hat sich die union denn richtig feind
wie stehen sie denn jetzt heute weiß ich
ja meinen anderen fall gebracht also das
was da frau fester gesagt hat fand ich
auch in der form völlig daneben so wird
auch eine gesellschaft nicht
zusammengeführt auch wenn sie bei den
grünen wahrscheinlichen fleiß pinien
kriegt weil sie korrekt geändert hat
aber das war kein auftritt der für unser
land gut und noch wesentlich ist was wir
ja gesagt haben also die impfpflicht
kann ja unter gewissen umständen
sinnvoll sein wenn man sicherstellen
kann ist kommt nicht so locker uns wir
haben dadurch keine überlastung auf den
intensivstationen und wir können damit
im prinzip verhindern dass grund und
freiheitsrechte eingeschränkt werden das
sind die bedingung aber die müssen auch
sichergestellt werden und im moment ist
es ja tatsächlich so dass wir im wissen
der impfstoff der hilft nicht so ganz
und gegen omikron haben wir noch keinen
wirklichen impfstoff es gibt viele impf
durchbrüche und wir haben derzeit keine
überlastung der intensivstation und wenn
diese bedingungen nicht gegeben sind
also dass man sagt da droht wirklich
wieder etwas das die intensivstation
überlastet werden dass ärzte nicht mehr
nachkommen dann finde ich gibt es auch
kein argument für eine impfpflicht und
deswegen haben wir als cdu gesagt wir
müssen jetzt uns schon darauf
vorbereiten auch auf den herbst und
winter und wenn wir wissen wir haben
einen impfstoff und es kommt wieder zu
einer schwierigeren situation dann
können wir über eine impfpflicht
entsprechen und möglicherweise auch die
karte ziehen aber wir dürfen nicht auf
einmal sagen wir beschließen einfach so
eine impfpflicht einfach so weil man das
gut findet und wenn diese im pflicht
nicht bringt nichts bringt dann wäre es
auch nicht sinnvoll und deswegen ist das
was die cdu und csu vorgeschlagen haben
genau der richtige mittelweg dass man
weiß man kann reagieren wenn es im
nächsten herbst und winter wieder nach
oben schießt denn das haben wir ja in
der letzten saison auch erlebt und das
hat dann wieder dazu geführt das ist
total locker uns kommt und das möchte
ich verhindern eine frage ganz christian
herr müller dann ohne hast du jederzeit
eine frage nur mls gibt es gibt viele
schauspieler in deutschland die schon
gesagt habe wie beispielsweise natalia
wörner sie würden nicht mit ungeimpften
drehen wenn es jetzt eine anfrage bei
ihnen gäbe fortsetzung gladiator ich
weiß es nicht werden sie auch mit einer
ungeimpften person drehen oder sehen sie
das wie manche schauspieler hier bei uns
in diesem land
dass die frage kommen kann gar nicht
aufkommen weil wie gesagt es ist so dass
wenn man an einem set geht eben halt
impfpflicht besteht ich habe jetzt
gerade vorletzten im dezember noch super
bowl commercial gedreht und wenn da wo
ich zweimal getestet welches einmal
positiv getestet worden dann hätte ich
dir nicht machen können also also am set
findet nach wie vor
noch im moment finden dort im fokus
stand man muss geimpft sein wenn man das
nicht macht dann hast du keinen job
was mich aufregt ist die unbelehrbarkeit
der politik wir führen heute wieder eine
diskussion auf basis der inzidenz wir
waren uns mal von mindestens einem jahr
einig dass die nichts mehr aussagen
sondern dass wir auf die kliniken
schauen wie viele leute liegen da mit
ernsthaften cupid erkrankungen in
behandlung das ist völlig harmlos heute
da redet aber kein mensch mehr darüber
sondern herr lauterbach und andere reden
wieder über die inzidenz als wäre nichts
gewesen und da muss ich sagen das ist
schon wie soll ich das nennen das nenne
ich groß haft weil die wissen es besser
aber sie wollen es gerne so haben weil
sie natürlich sich selber im geschäft
halten wollen auch im politischen
geschäft ich habe das früher mal gerona
mafia genannt und bin dafür heftig
kritisiert worden aber für mich gehört
karl lauterbach ist ein kopf der korona
mafia die leben davon dass es corona
gibt das sie die gesellschaft in schach
halten und dass sie der gesellschaft
auferlegen was sie zu tun oder zu lassen
hat und davon habe ich jetzt die nase
voll denn wir wissen dass dieses virus
war es jetzt unterwegs ist relativ
harmlos ist das kann im halben jahr
anders aussehen aber deswegen ist ja
unser vorschlag auch jahr richtig aber
es argumentieren sie doch heute mal mit
gegen lauterbach was habe ich doch
gemeint das sagen haben einen alarm
ministern haben ein einsames tagen also
die cdu-ministerpräsidenten rennen wenn
alle rum und widersprechen auch dem
neuen infektionsschutz avianca laut ich
sagen so häufig haben wir die karriere
ich habe in der sendung gesagt er ist
ein alarm minister ist ein angst
minister weil er tatsächlich im moment
angst und schrecken verbreitet und das
schlimme ist ja wenn ich das wenn herr
lauterbach das jeden tag tut dann wird
man ihn auch nicht ernst nehmen wenn es
mal drauf ankommt weil sich das
irgendwann abnutzt und wir müssen genau
die situation in den krankenhäusern im
blick behalten wenn es zum beispiel eine
neue mutante gibt die dazu führt dass
die krankenhäuser überfüllt werden
könnten dass die intensivstation
überlastet sein könnten da muss man
natürlich reagieren aber derzeit ist da
haben sie völlig recht ist das virus
eher so etwas wie ein schnupfen bei den
meisten menschen und es sorgt nicht
dafür dass die intensivstation überfüllt
sind wird deswegen gibt es im moment
auch keinen grund für eine impfpflicht
aber man muss sich nur von perry
schwieriger weil weil wir dürfen eines
nicht erleben dass wir nochmal drittes
mal in herbst und winter gehen und der
grund- und freiheitsrechten kommt der
männer viel herzlichen danke sie sich
zeit genommen haben
absolut recht nochmals jeder ist für
sich selbst verantwortlich
trainiert ernährt euch richtig genau und
lasst euch nicht weiter zurück von ab
und zu liberalen frauen ist ja durch
eine zigarette ist ja ich übrigens mit
oder sehr gut spielen angreifen
dankeschön
also jetzt wollen wir wieder
unterbrochenen diskussion oli diesmal
aber nicht von mir
ich wollte nochmal dem entgegenhalten
sie argumentieren im hinblick auf die
impfpflicht dort haben sie recht das
schildern viele man denn den
gesetzentwurf der union ich rede hier
über die augenblicke die diskussion wie
wir um den frieden day betrogen werden
und da spielen die ministerpräsidenten
union eine gute rolle denn die machen
alarmstimmung die sorgen dafür dass das
alles zunächst mal bis zum 2 april
verlängert wird und dann auch noch jetzt
darüber hinaus denn es gibt eine ganze
reihe von cdu ministerpräsidenten die
sich vorgenommen haben darüber wird
heute offen diskutiert und zwar mit karl
lauterbach die fdp zu betrügen und die
ganze beschränkung geschichte
fortzusetzen das sehe ich anders gerade
hamburg cdu ministerpräsidenten haben
sich dafür eingesetzt dass diese
maßnahmen zur milliardärin kommt dass
die maßnahme rück genommen werden ja ich
finde diesen begriff freedom day etwas
übertrieben der hat jetzt in der
politischen diskussion keine rolle
gespielt
aber was wir damit meint ja aber dass
das ist ja so ein kunstbegriff der jetzt
ja in den diskussionen wo man
tatsächlich dann ganz konkret sagen muss
wollen wir dass die menschen zum
beispiel wieder ins fußballstadion gehen
können oder nicht und da haben sich zum
beispiel gerade die cdu-politiker sehr
dafür eingesetzt dass die menschen
wieder in charlie in den schulen tragen
masken und
zeigen dass andere auch hier ich bin
auch ich bin zb sehr dafür dass die
massen pflicht an den schulen weit
zurückgenommen wird es hängt ist hängt
immer auch von der schule ab also man
muss jetzt mal gucken von bundesland zu
bundesland wobei ich ein punkt ganz
interessant wenn wir ich habe das selber
auch schon häufiger gesagt es gibt
gerade dann eltern die sich beschweren
und sagen das ist aber zu gefährlich
also das ist nicht unumstritten ja an
einem großen so gibt es alles ich will
jedenfalls ich habe die nase voll von
der massen pflicht im supermarkt solltet
ihr mal gestopft voll sein ziehe ich mir
vielleicht freiwillig einer auf aber ich
will da nicht zu gezwungen werden
ständig eine zu tragen